finding daughters hostage and at the end
of this journey where they four girls
have been taken hostage and they have
undergone a great deal of abuse they are
asked to identify this is after they've
round up Moki they've asked they've been
asked to identify they're the people
that have harmed them and every one of
those girls point to moking she was not
she was not even a quiet person even
with regards to that she was defiant she
was defiant right when they arrested her
and took her to Fort Marion Florida
which was a it was a Spanish a Spanish
fort and it was a really horrible place
to put these prisoners of war Moki being
the first Native American woman to be
taken as a prisoner of war
she was defiant even in there they
figured that she was so dangerous they
wouldn't even let her stay with the rest
of the Indians that were being held
there they put her in medicine water in
a different area she is released she's
supposed to be serving eight years she's
released after three and there's no home
for her to go go to she is sent to the
Oklahoma Panhandle area and there's just
no place she has no home now and I just
thought that this was a woman who was
willing to do what she had to to avenge
the loss of her people the loss of her
own family and I just admired that
dedication that she had to that idea but
I also am shocked and horrified by the
way that Cheyenne treated one another
treated people and by the way that the
government treated the Cheyenne there
was a part in the book that I marked
it's from the
September 8 1865 edition of Adelphi
weekly times and it says the sworn
account of witnesses of the affair is
enough to make any man blush for his
species and I think that that can be
held true whether it was the whites
attacking the Indians or the Indians
attacking the whites they did some
disabled things to one another I want to
read to you a section here about when
they take over this survey I think I do
hang on a second it's kind of
nerve-wracking because this is being
filmed by c-span and I'm trying to get
it out do I sound very serious and now
for c-span the chastity I want to read
to you 77 in 70 I don't want to read to
you the account of what was going on
with Moki when they came upon the German
family Moki who had participated in the
raid scanned the bodies as a German
family before she just mounted her ride
with an ax in hand she walked to John's
lifeless frame John being patriarch of
the family stopped studied the blood
gushing from his wounds and in aghast a
tribute to her own family who were
slaughtered at Sand Creek Loki drove her
axes of John's head and that did the
same to Lydia who was the matriarch of
the family according to Katherine
Germans reminiscences the Indians then
took what they wanted from our wagon and
in a short time my once happy family
life was forever ended I think the same
could have been said for Moki I think if
she could have written down that if she
would have said the exact same thing the
hope and happiness that I had for my
family was gone and that's what this
book is about it's about
Mokey's life in prison it's about what
she endured at fort marion it's about
the train ride
from from this this part of the country
all the way to Fort Marion and the the
horrible conditions of the Indian were
made to endure traveling there and I
want everyone to know that half of the
proceeds from this look the sale of this
book will go right to the Sand Creek
Massacre national site so when we leave
here don't just get one get two and I
hope that it will do continue to do well
and then it will make the people who
come to the Sand Creek Massacre and
proud and it would also raise awareness
to what took place here and to this
woman's life to have any questions from
anyone
thank you very much but you have a
question yes in Oklahoma she did she
died in 1881 she's 41 years old and she
died of tuberculosis after years of
being at Fort Mary yes ma'am
I happened on to an article written by a
wonderful author by the name of Linda
wool Mac she's done several books about
the history of Colorado and there were a
couple of paragraphs in there about
mochi and I felt how that I've got to
know more about this woman and so I
started digging and just kept doing that
for a long time and I just didn't want
to do a regular telling that everybody
else does or has done about Sand Creek
because this was very this was it seems
like more of a human interest piece and
not just facts about how many people
attacked whom but it was about the
emotion and about the horrific things
that you see and I think that we see so
many things even in our country right
now so many horrible things and it does
change us it's not to define who we are
but in moki's case I think it did yes I
know I explained it in the book but I
have a read I know that when I was I've
been through that when she was captured
it was like after like ten years of
being on this rampage seventy-five yes
what I mean how did they what did they
hold it for because I know that she said
she was like the first woman to be
imprisoned or something did they write
they I am sure it's in the book but they
tracked her down but you know me there
was a long there were a lot there was a
lot that happened after the same fig
Massacre and 64 to where she got to in
75 I mean she had she had remarried and
that trying to build a life with her and
medicine woman were trying to build a
medicine water we're trying to build a
life and they had children and say you
had some time passes there and then just
when they think things are being rebuilt
then you have the battle of Washita
where once again they're their camp is
attacked and this time it's by Custer so
and and then she thinks her her young
daughter is missing they can't find
medicine water's daughter so they look
and they look and even she looks through
the ashes and cannot find her her
daughter and she assumes that she just
drowned trying to get away I don't know
how you get over one loss or the loss of
a husband and your parents and then now
you think you're you're watching your
tribe being decimated and now you think
your daughter is gone I mean it it it
has to change you and then you know then
they go on this these raids I mean they
attack Julesburg and I think I'm I'm
pronouncing that correctly right is it
Gil's burg Colorado Julesburg Healdsburg
they they raid that they raid raid that
twice so there's a lot going on
it's not idle there's a lot going on and
then in between that time and then the
government just keeps tracking her and
they finally are able to get her and the
other boat string but she's even defiant
to the end I mean I likened her to a
female geronimo anybody else questions
yes well it would have been kind of an
offshoot of the dog soldier they were
the very they were a very fearful
warrior group Braves warriors face is
painted red with the yellow on either
side I mean they were very they were
relentless and that was the dark
soldiers is only for something for the
young and the bowstring was was kind of
like a subsidiary of that if you were
just to stuff
no women except smoking anyone else yes
ma'am
we're the raids mostly in eastern
Colorado no the raids were all over they
were from well they were from mules Berg
and - they did do some as far as far
east as the Oklahoma Territory but into
Texas they were everywhere wherever they
were ever they believed that people were
encroaching on territory that they
shouldn't be they shouldn't be on this
was there this was their fight
anyone else yes I apologize no that's
all right flipping through your book and
I happen to tell her um there's a picker
you were there what you were talking
about the Roper and the Ambrose lady and
there's a picture in here it shows in
that in in your book and my last name is
marble it's not real common and the
little boy in the pictures name is Danny
marble do we know that he survived said
that he was turned over to the yes Danny
survived Laura Roper was watching some
of the one of the children and I think
there were a couple of little children
and there were two grown women that were
taken as a part of that raid Laura Roper
and I believe mrs. Eubanks and the
children they had a child each with them
but they didn't belong to mrs. Rowe or
miss Roper who was going to be getting
married they belonged to us
mrs. Eubanks there's an account in there
by mrs. Eubanks who said when she was
with her son she the Indians kept saying
we want encouraging her to we her little
boy but she refused because she thought
if she did that that they would take him
and she's never seen him again you guys
are so nice to ask questions thank you
very much
anybody else have anything that yes
ma'am was she from the Arapaho or the
sign what Cheyenne she was saying
Cheyenne that doesn't mean you know this
I don't again this is this is about
moki's life could what Cheyenne so it is
in the bounce
I mean I've certainly mentioned the
Arapaho and the Kiowa who were there at
Sand Creek but I and also at the Bell of
life at all but I haven't spent a whole
lot of time on that because the story is
just a focus of mokey and then I do have
another question what happened to mokey
then did you follow through with her
family perhaps or present into the
present day sometimes stories will go
that way but what happened to her in the
end and maybe her family as well as I
said mokey dies from tuberculosis in
1881 at the age of 41 I don't know what
happened with medicine water I believe
that he did continue on I don't know if
he remarried and I don't really know
what happened with her daughter's I
didn't pursue that any further but
that's a good question that could be
something to be put in the epilogue of
the book as to what happened with her
daughter's I don't know I don't even
know if and maybe someone from some of
the directors from the site can answer
that did they take what would be a
census so we would know what happened to
these children I mean a lot of the
Cheyenne history is oral so how would we
know what happened to those two girls
that were hers
there were rolls that's right there's
the das rolls and then yeah after the
Dawes Act and so forth there were a lot
of records their airship records and
from that we've been able to piece
together some of the genealogy do you
know Jeff anything about what happened
to her children no specifically okay mr.
Moore at the site would probably be able
to answer that I just saw him and I
should have asked him while I was out
there but anyone else yes ma'am sorry
I'm very interested in history and
everything but if you wanted to look
into research that like just to continue
on for your own curiosity not would you
contact the Sand Creek site or I'm not
sure what site your recurring you I
think as you said the das roles and I
think you a great place to start is it
with Craig more out at the at the Sand
Creek site because I mean that they are
very knowledgeable fine didn't have dr.
Roberts helping me or Eric helping me I
mean when I wrote this I would sent them
and it wasn't just those two I sent it
says well I sent it too and he can't
remember the gentleman's name now but
they had of the Cheyenne tribe out of
Oklahoma I sent it to a couple of people
at the Bureau of into the interior
offices interior I just wanted to make
sure that's right so I mean you wouldn't
have to do some investigation that kind
of thing is it just it's not easy to
pick up we were so careful to make sure
that the history of what happened with
the white man was always written down I
don't think that we were asked careful
to do that with the Indians as I say a
lot of that was just oral history but I
think starting with Craig and that's
what I'm gonna do before I even leave
town I don't know where Craig's that but
I will find him
thank you all very much
we have books here that you can purchase
and as I say all of that today is going
to the Sand Creek Massacre national site
thank you very much you're watching book
TV nonfiction authors and books every
weekend on c-span - television for
serious readers
here's a look at some books that are
being published this week in a passion
for leadership Robert Gates recalls his
tenures as head of the CIA Texas A&M and
the Department of Defense former
senators Trent Lott and Tom Daschle
warned against the current partisanship
in government and lay out their
recommendations for how to move forward
in crisis point Christian political
activist Jim Wallace offers a critique
of race relations in America and his
fight against racism which he calls
America's original sin American governor
is journalist Matt Katz's biography of
New Jersey governor and 2016
presidential candidate chris Christie
also being released this week former
Democratic campaign manager Mary Beth
Rodgers provides a ten-point plan for
turning Texas blue in the rise and fall
of violent crime in America Barry Lazar
discusses why violent crime rose rapidly
in the 1960s and what has caused it to
fall in recent decades Washington Post
columnist EJ Dionne also looks at the
1960s and how the conservatism of Barry
Goldwater led to the rise of the Tea
Party in why the write went wrong in
gangster warlords Yoann Grillo reports
on the crime wars taking place in
Central and South America as well as the
Caribbean and staff writer for The New
Yorker Jane Mayer reports on the
political and economic underpinnings of
the conservative movement with a focus
on the libertarian views of Charles and
David Koch look for these titles in
bookstores this coming week and watch
for the authors in the near future on
book TV ok
are we ready well I want to thank you
all for coming today this is a big
thrill to be able to be working in the
Boston Public Market at the kitchen with
the folks from the the trustees of the
reservation I and doing this off with
Anastacia and it is for c-span books
this is a great thrill and this is the
first time we've ever done a c-span
books filming in this space is first
time actually we filmed in this space so
we're really quite thrilled on all
levels let me introduce myself first I'm
Louisa Kasdan and I'm the CEO and
founder of let's talk about food and
every Friday in this space we run a
program that we call our brown bag
lunches and you'll see in the back there
are people who are eating some of those
lunches but our goal every week is to
sort of shine a bright light on
different aspects of food in our world
and I am particularly thrilled today
that the world that we're going to be
shining light on is the world of
combat-ready
kitchen combat-ready food food that has
been impacted it's it's a revealing book
that really talks about and studies in
great detail and humorous great detail
all the aspects of how armies how
military civilizations from the Aztecs
on up have managed to feed their
soldiers so it is my great pleasure to
introduce Anastasia who comes through
this topic as a much much acclaimed food
writer she's written for gourmet she's
written for the Boston Globe she does
NPR recordings she does an NPR blog this
is this is a really a remarkable book
that she's created and it's going to be
fascinating to listen to her explain to
us how the military has impacted the
food that we eat Thank You Anastasia let
me give you her entire name she is
Anastasia marks justice a doe and the
story behind her name is probably just
as interesting as
itself thank you thank you Louisa good
afternoon everyone and thanks to the
Boston Public Market and let's talk
about food friend having me here today
before I get going with my remarks I'm
just wondering if anyone in the audience
has wants to estimate for me what
percentage of these items up here might
have a military origin or influence yes
okay yes it is good good okay anybody
else how about you a hundred percent of
these foods have a military influence or
origin I'm not going to go over them all
in the talk because there's so many but
you're certainly welcome to come up
afterwards and ask me about them okay my
my journey into this topic started with
a sandwich I'm a mother and I packed a
lot of lunches and when I do that I
usually look for a balance between what
I considered to be the healthy items the
sandwich the grapes the carrot sticks
and the child pleasing but not so
healthy items such as the juice pouch
the energy bar and the goldfish crackers
and one day when I was doing that I was
putting together sandwich and maybe I
was a little bit caffeine-deprived that
day and a little grumpier than usual but
I started thinking this sandwich isn't
really any healthier or fresher than the
other ingredients in packages and that
in fact every component the bread the
cheese the processed meat and even the
mayonnaise had come from packages that
had been in my fridge or my breadbox and
before that they had been in the
supermarket and before that in the
manufacturing facility so I started to
do research after I sent the kids off to
school on each of the ingredients and in
particular why they all seemed so
strangely
lived and what I found was that at the
origin of two of them the supermarket
bread and the packaged deli meat
there was this reference just this
obscure US military base the Natick
soldier system center and I said to
myself what's the army doing in our food
the Natick soldier system Center is
actually about 15 minutes west of here
in Natick Massachusetts it's one of 80
Department of Defense federal
laboratories around the country there
are facilities on a 78 acre campus it's
wooded next to this beautiful lake and
there they develop everything to support
the individual soldier so that's our
textiles Footwear tents combat armor
airdrop equipment environmental medicine
and of course combat rations the combat
feeding director is this really cute
teal and blue striped building and it's
surrounded by this rusting field
equipment like a battlefield kitchen and
a containerized channel a chapel which
is you know what what it sounds like
it's actual chapel inside the metal
container and it there they have about
300 employees most of whom are civilians
many food scientists and technologists
and their primary job is to develop and
perfect combat rations which by federal
mandate have to be able to last for
three years at 80 degrees Fahrenheit so
they take that process from soup to nuts
it starts with what's called a
formulation which is basically an
industrial recipe involves a lot more
ingredients and a lot more scientific
sounding ingredients than your food at
home they do chemical analysis they
create the packaging for it and they do
test
of the rations in in simulated battle
field conditions dropping it from big
heights and jiggling and squashing it
and leaving it in very hot chambers for
a certain amount of time and then they
they also perfect and change and swap in
those menu items every year so those
things get rotated regularly the two
main individual combat ration lines one
is the MRE most people have heard of
that the meal ready-to-eat and that
entered the field in 1981 and big
innovation there was that the entree was
in a pouch a foil and plastic pouch
instead of a cam and so inside the pouch
you're gonna find something like
barbecued pork you might find penne
pasta
they actually have halal meals or a
burger and you'll there'll be a pouch
with some bread in it a processed cheese
bread might have jalapenos maybe some
snack items a dessert and a beverage the
other individual soldier combat line is
the first dry crashing and the first
strike ration will first enter the field
in 2007 and it actually came about
because during their most recent wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan commanding officers
noticed that soldiers were doing what
they called field-stripping the MRE that
is taking the snack items and leaving
behind all the nutritional ones with
them when they went into the field and
so the army decided to go with the flow
on that and to just develop this whole
what they call a grazing line so inside
the first strike you'll find things like
three-year shelf stable sandwiches you
will find soon or if not already a three
year shelf stable pizza wraps and then
snack items jerky candy energy bar and a
beverage
I don't think it says anything good
about us but combat rations actually go
back to the beginning of recorded
history so let's do a whirlwind tour of
some of the major warrior cultures in
history here okay so the first recorded
war was an ancient Sumer 3500 to 2200 BC
and it was in the very same global
hotspot that's been keeping us so busy
for the past couple of decades the
details of that war are etched into the
Stelly of vultures that's a deal that's
a piece of it
and there were 18 city-states in ancient
Sumer and they basically were at each
other's throats for thousands of years
which gave rise some some very nasty
weaponry the sickle sword and the socket
axe and I'm not going to talk about that
because they're very gory as well as to
the world's first combat rations and
those were barley cakes beer the
Sumerians were very fond of beer they
actually dedicated 40% of their crops to
beer production and green onions okay
our next stop is H in Egypt 2200 to 1000
BC and this civilization was really
stable in large part because it was
geographically isolated there was a
Mediterranean Sea to the north the
Sahara to the west a big river running
through it and to the east another
desert so they didn't have many visitors
but eventually they were invaded by the
Hyksos who were automatic people and
that spurred them to transform
themselves into a military power once
their military power they started
decided to keep going with it and they
went expansionist and eventually
acquired 400,000 square miles of
territory
to supply this territory with food and
with fodder they actually invented a
profession which is called the
quartermaster who sent things around
with little naval ships and oxen and
they also made a major contribution to
rations with the addition of a preserved
protein and that was dry fish and it was
so important that Egyptian soldiers
received an allotment of right fish
every three months as part of their
wages and the rest of the rations were
kind of like those of the Sumerians
bread beer and green onions okay now
we're going to move on to Rome 509 BC to
479 ad and this is where our rations
story takes a tasty twist in fact the
Roman Legionnaires were responsible for
the spreading wide and far of their
taste for salumi which is preserved pork
products and the reason for that stems
from two things first only landed
citizens could join the army which meant
that soldiers were farmers and they had
by then discovered the pig pigs are
really easy to raise because you can
feed them forage and table scraps they
drop litters up to two times a year of
810 piglets and those piglets reach
maturity in just six months so they are
basically protein factories the other
factor was the Romans controlled the
world salt trade and they actually paid
their fighters in salt and they used all
that mineral to preserve their pork the
upshot was mountains of prosciutto hams
bacon and sausage which formed the
backbone of the Roman combat rations in
addition they had hard tack which was a
twice-baked ancestor to the cracker hard
cheese such as parmesan and garam which
is fermented fish sauce
I think of the Mongols twelve of twelve
thousand and six - sorry twelve 1206 -
1294 ad as the predecessor to today's
special ops
they were consummate horsemen and they
practically lived in the saddle they
were incredibly tough
they rode for days just swapping in
mounts from a string of horses that ran
behind them and they slept in the cold
and freezing ground without any bedding
their rations were similarly hardcore
they consisted of powdered milk which
the Mongols actually invented and they
would reconstitute that by putting it in
the saddlebag with water and letting the
jiggling of the horse make this kind of
frothy beverage and the other mainstay
was jerky which they'd cured under the
saddle with the weight of the rider and
the sweat from the salt from the sweat
of the horrors yes I know it sounds very
tasty and then finally they had a very
original emergency ration which was that
they would slit open a vein on their
horse's neck and drink hot blood when
they ran out of food so they were they
assembled the largest contiguous land
Empire ever ever and they killed between
15 and 30 million people during the
reign which is a number I found
astronomical okay before I go any
further I just want to ask is there
anybody here who belonged to a sorority
or a fraternity oh okay well all right
please bear with me because I have very
very unfairly unfairly here described
the Vikings as the frat bros of the
major warrior cultures since they
dominated Europe from the late 8th to
the early 11th centuries based on brawn
and nothing of brainpower they were
farmers also and they set out from the
north in Long ships which were built for
speed and
new virility to raid villages in the
British Isles and on the French coast
and they're quick and bloody incursions
were enhanced by berserkers who were
naked wild men high on reindeer piss
which is a loose-knit in any way that
however boisterous they're on Shore
antics their their shipboard diet was
very dispiriting barley mush butter and
dried Cod we're gonna close with our
neighbors the Aztecs who dominated the
Mesoamerican Basin from 14:27 to 1519 in
one of the most bizarre and bloodthirsty
warrior cultures on the planet it's
worth noting that this was a temperate
region with very few natural water
sources and low annual rainfall so that
left it prone to crop failures and it's
also worth noting that the Mesoamerican
Basin had no large mammals that could be
domesticated as livestock as did other
cradles of civilization at any rate
during that time period after some
repeated crop failures three cities
Aztec city-states
led by its quatl and Moctezuma joined
together and conquered the joining
territories to either coast the Atlantic
and the Pacific and as far south is what
is now Guatemala but they didn't demand
any of the traditional spoils of war
they just wanted food so they had edible
tributes and they marched off the enemy
soldiers who had been captured brought
them to their capital ritually
sacrificed them and then ate them this
they were even only by elites who
included the Warriors and I'm not going
to say any more about that except that I
will note that the the Aztec warriors
every
diet was extremely monotonous it
included dried toasted tortillas and
ground chia amaranth and pumpkin seeds
okay so now we're gonna pause for a
moment and digest all this information
and try and understand what are some
characteristics of rations does anybody
want adventure a go ahead yeah that's
definitely one there light and portable
anybody else guess they're dry yes light
and they remove the weight and dry is a
characteristic often of a what kind of a
food preserved a preserve it so we have
a preserved food so that it can last a
long time it's it's light so that it's
portable it's rugged because well a
soldier's life in the field is pretty
rugged and finally it's nourishing and
at least in antiquity that often meant a
preserved protein and guess what those
are pretty much the same characteristics
of rations today ok so now I'm gonna
fast-forward a little bit and we're
going thank you we're going to go to the
late 18th century and we're gonna take a
peak in the rough sacks of the American
and French revolutionary soldiers and
see what they have let's see they have
hardtack bacon flour some beans does
that sound at all familiar yeah it's
pretty much the same thing that the
Romans had almost 2,000 years earlier
why was that well food preservation
techniques had stalled and back you know
around the birth of Christ and they
they're people were still using before
standbys of drying salting pickling and
smoking
all that was about to change and it
would mark the very first moment that
the military got involved in food
science and guess what it's been
involved ever since
so in 1895 the French agricultural
department probably responding to hunger
and starvation experienced by both
soldiers and citizens during the French
Revolutionary War issued a challenge to
any would-be Food Technologists to see
if they could come up with a fifth major
way to preserve food and they would be
given an award of twelve thousand francs
that challenge was met by a guy named
Nicholas a pear necklace up hair was a a
bad-boy celebrity chef he cooked for
royalty and then with his riches he
retired to open a candy shop and he
retired very young and then you know we
before he had turned 30 and that
actually provided well the keys still
working he's making candy that provided
the perfect setting to do food science
experiments and so a pair spent probably
a decade working and you know through
how to preserve food using his equipment
in the evening and he kept bringing it
to the French government and asking them
if it met with their approval and he
kept getting either ignored or sent back
and told things like oh the broth is too
weak and so forth but eventually in 1809
they accepted what he had offered and
what it was was food that had been put
inside a glass container and in the last
container had been put inside boiling
water in a larger container and slowly
cooked for a period of time and then he
would stop up the glass container now a
pair didn't know this it would take
Pasteur sixty years later to figure out
what was actually happening but what he
was doing was he was killing all the
microorganisms inside the food and then
by putting closing up the container all
was still hot no new microorganisms
could enter in eighteen
the franchisor cultural department
awarded him the 12,000 francs in return
for relinquish in his claim to his
discovery which he did that discovery
was canning and it really revolutionized
the world it's still one of the most
important food preservation techniques
in our larder and a pair he died a
popper and anonymous and I feel like
that there should be a moral here but
only when I could get was don't be a
government contractor I don't think
that's the one they want to I want to
promote okay
the second major foray into food science
by the military came almost a hundred
and fifty years later when the u.s.
entered World War two and suddenly the
army had to ramp up from feeding 400,000
soldiers to 11.6 and to put that in a
little more scale saleable terms for us
it would be as if you if you have a
dinner party for twelve and suddenly
received word that three hundred eighty
five people were going to attend to say
that the quartermaster Corps I don't
remember that word quartermaster
supplies for the army was prepared to do
this would have been an understatement
in 1941 when the war started they had
just two modern rations the sea ration
and I say modern because they were both
ready to eat and portable the sea ration
which is a stew in a can and the de
ration which was a deliberately
inedible chocolate bar it was intended
to be an emergency ration that's why was
inedible and they didn't want the guys
eating the chocolate goes I mean who can
resist chocolate and this they had a
basically no food rude research they had
a small lab with three employees with
develop these two rations and no outside
projects these rations did not fare well
when they were shipped all around the
world
they spoiled they molded the food
developed off-flavors
fat separated out and different
ingredients separated they got
discolored the packaging fell apart and
the cans rusted and in response to that
the army created the biggest food and
packaging science program that had ever
been created and that that little
laboratory in Chicago that had started
with three people by the end of the war
had 300 employees it had different focus
areas from food chemistry to nutrition
vitamins and sensory evaluation and they
had over 500 outside projects with
industry and universities that system
has pretty much stayed in place intact
okay at this point you're probably
saying great this is wonderful
information about combat rations but
what does it have to do with consumer
food and the answer to that sounds a
little bit like a conspiracy theory and
it is preparedness after the war to
avoid having to go through that painful
process of gearing up to meet the
demands of a global conflict the
government decided that it was just
maintained in a state of perpetual
readiness the military and the
industrial sector that supported it so
if we apply that policy to subsistence
to food it means that the action the
army actually has and I kid you not here
it actually has a mandate to get the
food signs used in combat rations into
consumer food items and that's so that
if hey World War three comes along at a
moment's notice
DoD is going to ask craft or ADM or
formel to convert their production line
directions that whole process was
actually codified in the 1980s as sort
of an economic development measure and
it's something called technology
transfer now
this going to be very super quick on
this because this is kind of the policy
stuff I missed that but the way that
technology transfer works oh this is
remember the way that the government's
getting the science and technology that
it develops into the private sector is
journals conferences informal
conversations letting companies use
patents for free or for a nominal fee
contracts and grants and then this is a
very important category joint research
projects and one of those is called
accreta
the created the cooperative research and
development agreement and the Natick
combat feeding directorate create a list
of
creative collaborators literally reads
like the top 20 largest food and
packaging companies in the United States
and those are some of them ADM Campbell
Soup can Agra Dr Pepper Snapple
frito-lay PepsiCo etc okay so now going
back to my sandwich story at the
beginning of the talk here is my
daughter on her way to school and here
here's her lunchbox so let's unpack it
for all the military influences hmm
raise your hand if you like Cheetos who
doesn't like Cheetos well Cheetos and
all these kind of cheesy snack and
convenience foods they're critical
ingredient comes from the military
during World War two because the
government was shipping such a huge
volume of food overseas was looking for
ways to reduce the weight and and the
the volume so it decided to dehydrate as
many things as possible dehydration
reduced water water is the major
component of most food at 70% of animal
tissue 90% of plant tissue and so it ran
through the drying chambers everything
from milk and eggs and fruits and
vegetables and then it tried cheese well
when I got to cheese it had a problem
because cheese doesn't have an internal
structure so what happened when it
dehydrated cheese had just collapsed
into a powder but not to be deterred the
army packed that into little tins sent
it overseas to cooks and they used it as
an ingredient in main dishes side dishes
and sauces after the war a little cheese
dehydration industry had grown in
Wisconsin where cheddar comes from and
it no longer had a customer so it looked
to the grocery manufacturers of America
and provided them with this new and
exciting dehydrated cheese ingredient M
lo and behold shortly thereafter it
began appearing and the consumer markets
started with the cheeto and just I'm
sure you were dying to know how the
cheeto is made it is a corn dough which
is pushed through an extruder it's a
special machine under pressure and pass
up then it's fried in in hot oil and
sprayed with dehydrated cheese okay
let's see have notice that your
supermarket bread never goes stale don't
you think that's kind of weird
traditional bread that you get from a
baker
that's actually really scientifically
starts just say the minute comes out of
the oven and two days later it's a rock
right well you can think the US Army for
the fact that you have long live red
this comes from an initiative during the
1950's when the army decided that
definitely it had to have bread to give
men and women in the field until then
men and women in the field had to eaten
guess what hardtack basically didn't
like it very much and then the Army has
spent a special unit of Baker's who
prepared fresh bread in garrison camps
the garrison soups are the big stable
camps so in the 1950s it began to work
on this project in earnest and it had a
number of technical difficulties but one
of course is stealing and what it did
was to ask a contractor which was the
Kansas State University to add bacterial
enzymes to the bread now all bread has
enzymes and one of the important ones is
amylase which breaks down starches into
sugar and in bread that sugars and
consumed by the yeast and the yeast
extrudes carbon dioxide and it makes the
bread rise and makes bread nice and
fluffy in traditional bread the amylase
comes from two sources it comes from the
yeast and it comes from the wheat the
yeast is a fungi the wheat is a plant
they both have a real they prefer a
relatively cool
temperature range which means that their
enzymes are inactivated by baking some
bacteria can tolerate very high
temperatures that means that their
amylases can also tolerate high
temperatures so what this concert did is
it took the enzymes from bacteria added
them to the bread and that meant they
weren't inactivated by baking and
continue to break down the starch for
days and weeks afterwards it took
several decades to work out all the
different technical issues but that
technology is used routinely now in
supermarket lives to keep the bread soft
and fresh
cling-wrap this had to come from the
government in it during again back in
World War two there were tremendous
shortages of natural materials so one of
the things that the government did was
to sponsor a huge classified research
program into developing synthetic
substitutes for everything this was
centered at the Polytechnic Institute of
Brooklyn and headed up by a guy named
Herman mark who was an Austrian polymer
scientist and he was asked to find
replacements for everything from shower
curtains and raincoats shoelace tips
bugles I'm not sure why because was on
the list handles for all sorts of tools
and and for food packaging at that time
food packaging used cellophane and
cellophane is based on cellulose which
and it's a plant based polymer and not
very resistant to water which is why the
rations were admitting water and falling
apart as we talked about earlier so the
innovation here was it that mark went to
the Dow Chemical Company and they had
this polymer called Saran
was very water resistant but they hadn't
been able to do much with it except they
used it to spray engines and so forth
when they were shipped on deck overseas
is kind of this oily green stuff and in
mark's
classified polymer lab they kind of
worked the kinks out of turning that
into a film and then it had a lot of
difficulties with light sunlight and
with just with tom he would kind of fall
apart and become brittle and discolored
they did that and dow was so excited by
that that on four days after Hitler
committed suicide on April 30th 1945 it
had rushed to the US Patent Office to
apply for a patent for sarandphil
and that appeared again in the consumer
market a few years later first in
restaurant and industrial kitchens and
then in our kitchens where it's pretty
much been ever since hmm okay I'm kind
of curious here how many of you if you
don't have an energy bar on your person
have one at home or in your office okay
well what what and what do you think
that this might have satisfied for in
the military just now they know a little
bit about it
all right I murdered it's an emergency
ration okay yeah so the great granddaddy
of the energy bar is actually this
unpalatable chocolate bar the D ration
that we talked about that was produced
during World War two by Hershey and
continued to be produced up until the
end of the 20th century but then the
army took that concept and started doing
other things with it the first thing it
did is that it tried to turn to create a
whole system of food bars just food bars
to feed soldiers on in the field so the
idea was they would have like a bacon
and eggs bar a cereal bar a for lunch
they might have a pea soup bar or a
macaroni and cheese bar and the part I
like best about this was that they had
also come up with the idea of laminated
condiment booklets so you're gonna have
this little square bar of food and then
you'd rip off like say a little a sheet
of ketchup or a sheet of jam and put it
on top of your bar and that was how
you're gonna spice up your food this
actually never got fielded but when NASA
was looking for a way to feed astronauts
that it went to Natick and Natick said
hey we've got the system why don't we
use that and so with a little tweak
which is an important week which is to
turn the bars into cubes so that they
wouldn't emit potentially
life-threatening crumbs because in in
space with zero gravity x' crumbs can be
a problem that is actually what went up
on the first manned space flights there
was a small problem freeze-dried food
actually subtracts moisture from your
mouth when you're eating it so you end
up with a major case of dry mouth and
the astronauts were very unhappy with it
and in fact they lost weight and had
other gastrointestinal symptoms and
complained heartily however Natick and
NASA continued to get to send
freeze-dried food into space but they
immediately began working on another
option that option was inspired by a
visit to the supermarket where they
found the gaines burger which is a
shelf-stable dog food patty and it was
the dog food patty was able to be moist
and chewy at room temperature because of
something called water activity which is
was a theory that had been developed in
the late 1950s and was a different
understanding of what made things boil
or Harbor pathogenic bacteria and it was
that instead of straight-up water
content it's the amount of water
available that is to say not bound up in
the food and so this meant that if you
could get the water activity down a
little bit so that it was inhospitable
to bacteria and fungi that you could
still have a moist food so the Nate
Exeter had some MIT scientists working
the kinks out of this one of them moved
to the University of Minnesota and in
1971 the very first chewy modern energy
bar went up into space and was eaten on
the Apollo 15 mission it was apricot
flavor and the contactor on that project
then turned around and worked with all
the major ready-to-eat cereal companies
to develop their own granola bars
Pillsbury Quaker Oats General Mills and
that was the first wave of the energy
bar it's gone through a couple others
but now as you know what occupies like a
quarter aisle in the supermarket okay
this is straight up ration packaging I
don't have to talk about that because it
was a replacement for the tin can
developed by the Army in the 1960s it
was a complicated project make it meant
Traynham really it had to transform the
can and flexible packaging industry and
once it was completed
it's what the MRE comes in and once it
was completed it really took off in Asia
where there is less refrigeration it's
been a little slower in the US market
but juice makers have hit upon there's a
great packaging for our kids lunches
okay our final item here is the McRib
and I'm gonna knock this one down the
the McRib actually comes out of a 1960s
military program to reduce the cost of
their meat bill by sixty percent and the
reason that they imagined that they
might be able to do this is during that
period the meat the meat initiative of
America made a switch from selling meat
on the carcass to meat in boxes and in
boxes it can be sorted by cut now that
itself was a military innovation which
I'm not going to talk about if you want
you can check it out in the book but the
so when the army got involved not as
decided that it was going to make a
change the change that it made was not
however to just buy steak for the
soldiers it was to buy this